ready for a game six this should be fun
all of these games have been dramatic
rays are back to being the home team for
game six of the american league
championship series lake snell makes his
warm-up tosses today coming out of the
shadows the 6'5 left-hander and what has
to be the biggest start of his career to
this point the two-two pitch on its way
and there is strike three called tim
timmons with the ring up at 96 and
springer is punched down for the first
out of this friday afternoon so duvet
with good speed is aboard one on one out
and here's michael brantley the 3-2
pitch runner goes in this honest way so
i'm gonna miss strike three throw down
the second it's a good one and altuve is
out from here to pasadena uh strike him
out throw him out double play and the
left-hander on the mount fromber valdez
how good has he been he has been highest
ground ball rate during the regular
season 60 he's raised that to 67 percent
in the postseason one two
swing and a miss got him on the curve
ball one out you'll see pitchers
sometimes to start off a batter behind
an account that wasn't it three two
swinging a miss another hook and renfro
goes down on strikes to in the inning
here's alex fragrant there's infield
looking to turn two blake from the set
in the pitch to bregman here's a swing
and a hard hit shot to third pick by
wendell on one hop he goes to second out
throws the first double play and
bregman's got to be wondering what does
he have to do to get a hit off of blake
snell that had to be well over a hundred
miles an hour off the back back to back
walks with two outs here's elena's diaz
a roller in the hole above his back
hands it got a long throw and it's a
good one strong arm shortstop two outs
runner first and willing to dominate the
battery now the one pitch swing and a
drive to the gap in left center this is
going to get down and go to the wall
over to go get it as springer around
second on his way to third is loud he
loses the helmet here's the relay to the
plate it's not going to take place
brandon lau slides in safely it's
one-nothing raise here in the second
william adams with an rbi double gives
the raise the lead the lead that the
rays have just been aching for lately
and everybody on the race has seemed to
feel that they had to get a lead today
to give themselves a chance to win and
willy adams with two out provides it but
if you do allow yourself to think about
tomorrow you're hoping valdez can go
deep deep deep so you have to be
efficient here breaking ball got him
strike three
that's six strikeouts for frohmber and
there's two away all of them on the
curve every single one payoff pitch two
outs
and he lost him so rosarena is aboard
all right big pitch here runner will be
going here's the pitch breaking ball
strike three got him valdez dropped it
in there
another curveball all seven strikeouts
on that yakker
and cash is going to go to the fireman
right now
and snell is furious
four plus two batters for snell and
their ace is out with two runners that
are his responsibility and let's see if
diego's got a little houdini in him
again so now george springer will try
and make something happen he has struck
out twice today the pitch
and that's a ground ball right side and
through for a base hit that'll score
guriel diaz around third and coming home
the throw will go to second base as diaz
scores standing up the astros take the
lead on springer's two-run single two to
one boy what a great piece of hitting by
springer and now it's altuve's turn
first pitch and jose drives this one
deep down the left field line ball is
hooking and it one hops over off the
wall and on his way to third is springer
he's around third and coming home and he
will score an rbi double for jose altuve
to make it three to one astros
correa has singled and struck out 1-1
ground ball left side out of the reach
of wendell and then the left field
altuve scores and it's 4-1 astros carlos
correa drives in his third run of the
series
we found the hole right in between the
third baseman and shortstop and the
astros are stringing them together now
three infielders on the left side for
zunino with the shift on o2 pitch and a
you know maybe one or two pitches here
take a chance and sit on a curve
one two swing and a miss got him with a
two-seamer that's valdez's first
strikeout on something other than the
curveball he's with nine today and he
strands a runner and the rays turn to
their third pitcher of the day it is
left-hander shane mcclanahan tucker over
one with a walk 2-0
and tucker lifts this one pretty deep to
left center margot is going back at the
wall see you later
kyle tucker's first extra base into the
postseason is a home run and the astros
lead is five to one and the kid from
tampa will touch them all and give the
astros a four-run lead now what a swing
of the bat first career post-season home
run
and all smiles for the astros they have
found their offensive game here in the
last two innings
he had left dusty hanging he came back
can't leave the skipper hanging maybe a
parting shot here hit the ball rolling
in the right direction something to show
a sign of life with this offense 3-2
pitch to diaz on its way check swing did
he go the last good first i don't think
he did and he did not and now what's
going on here with valdez and diaz
they're having some words and and i
think this is
a spot right here for yandi i mean you
get under the kid's skin there's two on
with one out
and brandon lau lowe's coming up carlos
correa now he is
in a serious pep talk with fraumer
valdez and that has everything to do
with don't let these guys talk to you
that way you show up runners lead off
first and second another 2-2
ground ball right side right out el tuve
shovels a second for one correa on the
first that's a double play score at
4-6-3 and the inning is over so it
wasn't easy but frauber got through it
strands a runner astros 5 raise one
the stare down i'm not messing with that
the intensity of this
post season
two va in scoring position here's the
two two breaking balls pulled to the
right side and it gets by brasso has it
go off his glove altuve will score on
the rbi single by brantley and the
astros lead it six to one see if tucker
can knock him in brantley's on third
correa is on second here's the pitch and
he rips it left field going back on it
is lao and he's gonna make the catch at
the warning track tagging at third base
as brantley he'll score and the astros
lead seven to one so it's gonna be andre
scrub here manuel margot there's a long
drive deep to left field that'll make
margot feel good all the way back to the
wall it's gone home run
manuel margot a solo homer and it's
seven to two houston brandon lowell
worked the walk right there margot is
homer grounded a third and struck out
looking first pitch swinging another one
deep in the air towards left field
turning and looking as tucker to the
wall
gone home run off the ribbon board
manuel margot with a two-run home run
it's seven to four houston now it's
brasso who is over three with a wall
gray's need another base runner to get
the tying run to the plate two strike
pitch
ground ball left side to his left
correct a second for one altuve on the
first in time and that is the ball game
there will be a game seven as the
houston astros defeat the tampa bay rays
by a final score of 7-4